hello and welcome to co playing
Wolverine Brazil yeah Kara I remember he
always places pleasant to be no knees
and okay know him you probably get
amarok see binder know what's sd-6 hmm
if I take it it's a very strange move
water okay I don't try to exploit it
just plain all the moves so we get some
kings in the entire position after all a
six
okay once the take f3 takes you four mmm
I don't like 92 that much
can probably not much of an alternative
I don't like to trade this yeah it's a
typical picture you have played him a
lot and I never understand the move he
plays so many moves that I consider
completely entire positional that never
ever have a tough time to commentate
that black should be ecstatic that he
can take only two instead he goes back
to 87 very strange this is why I was so
reluctant to play 92 because black has
helped a lot by trading the bishops but
he is not doing it simply yeah now is
sitting there with all his minor pieces
and has no space for them and okay so
this one a form okay this it's a very
sharp position still I wonder if before
is a movie in just simple but simple
chest but okay I think a stuff like this
is also good
I would like to play before him would
make the black Queen side pieces look
really strange
before now it's eerily angling for
Bishop takes h3 em and talk to believe
but ok I can do this just a tech t6
okay so can I can I can also still go
back to that be4 idea I think I'll do
that not sure that was probably also the
right decision earlier my DHS Bishop be
six winning the winning the night
yeah I don't think it should work the
ending at the end of speed must be
clearly better for void our canine tix
he wants to check on d5
call chicks Knight takes Knight a group
chicks Knight f6 check though
check check okay so let's think about
this for just one moment I can also go
back attacking this again and what is
this currently I'm found the peas
upright so I just have to not blunder
something back and should win so and
this it takes a look OOP t1 no look c3i
go nite have six I guess
I can I can also just attack the rook
and this is probably easier just like
rook to e1 Bishop see to know check tall
that one black resigns I was in a hard
time against this play because it just
makes so many weird decisions that my
commentary sound sound strange sometimes
because you know I really took a long
time here because I have to play 92 I
think and this is not a move I want to
play because it can take on e to which
it doesn't do this is just a pretty
serious jejeje era of course black wants
to trade stuff he has less space and the
bishop in particular is useless is why i
was a bit angry that i had to play 92
the engine actually believes be three is
good which I simply couldn't I couldn't
play because I felt like there is too
much vulnerability here on those on
those squares b3 and seasonal those
pieces maybe it's better though engine
doesn't see it doesn't give anything
that I lose the porn or something like
that and then this is preferable but 97
is a big big position of blunder simply
you have to trade down now why this is a
lot better with various ideas one thing
was before maybe I should have done that
right here I couldn't really I couldn't
really make up my mind if I want to play
with f4 on like Age 3 F 45 or before
maybe before it's the simplest thing you
know he has to take luke takes Bishop b6
as a threat and now black already has to
do something drastic otherwise she just
uses the night down a five the engine
gives this so I'm just doing stuff him I
guess
g4 is still interesting okay so there
are still some tricks the computer
computer wants to do this that's in nice
one interesting or simply this one at
the beep one is pretty strong in the
night on e5 yeah before what's the
principal alternative but i thought okay
i can just I know Howie five would have
one immediately probably I didn't see
that one takes Bishop c5 it's very awful
as before is also in the mix okay that's
terrible I can I just kept the position
as this I am no 94 with 1 immediately
gather there were a couple of better
things but this is also very nice night
before that was very strong I didn't
consider that and threatens this and
this and black is basically playing a
piece down there 185 someone came I mean
probably what I'm doing is also pretty
okay that's like plum plus 1.7 but it's
not as forceful as it was possible to do
the end him I'm a lot better but after
that I'm it's completely lost and this
is what the engine is giving and yeah
okay that's nice for white objectively
winning probably but still has to be
done t I'm just am just material up for
nothing mmm gay always quite frequently
placed strategically weird weird moves
like Bishop d7 which is just really bad
and something to remember if you have
less space and slightly misplaced pieces
you should trade stuff and not play in a
position where you have your kind of
cramped I mean the thing is he would
like to have d7 maybe for the night oops
I'm sorry for the night and he should be
absolutely happy that
and traded yeah of course but what he
didn't it just didn't do it Bishop d7
back okay well thanks for watching